I woke up around four o'clock in the  morning just about every day part of  that came because I started in the  fitness industry and I was doing that  anyways also because I didn't have to  talk to anyone until about 10 a.m and so  that gave me about six hours of  uninterrupted work time that I could  really move projects for so that means  the first thing I did every morning was  I would wake up and I would start  working and at the end of the day if I  look at a Year everyone else who's  competing against me is still working in  their business but if I wake up at three  o'clock or four o'clock in the morning  and I can work three or four hours until  eight o'clock or nine o'clock I get more  done in that period of time than most  those guys are getting done in a week